on va retrouver justement à auxerre
cressant marot le candidat donc de la
droite qui vient mettre en ballottage le
maire sortant guy férez ce qui est sans
voir au bon soin et tout d'abord une
réaction sur votre score
bonsoir donc c'est un score encourageant
qui confirme une vraie volonté de
changement à auxerre donc nous allons
essayer de transformer l'essai la
semaine prochaine vous le dites avec un
certain sourire dans un contexte
difficile vous avez l'impression que les
gens se sont déplacés quand même et que
votre votre score est tout à fait
logique et est valide
j'ai envie de dire alors je ne me
permettrais pas d'analyser les chiffres
dans un contexte aussi exceptionnel je
crois que c'est quasiment inédit en
france ce qui est en train de se
produire et je confirme que la sécurité
publique avant tout cependant nous
sommes dans le cadre d'une élection donc
nous faisons campagne
quelles que soient les hypothèses qui
seront retenus la semaine prochaine nous
continuerons notre travail de proximité
tels que vous nous l'avons fait durant
plusieurs mois très saint maron la
situation d'auxerre c'est qu'il ya deux
listes écologistes l'écologie c'était un
des phénomènes attendu on va tirs dans
cette élection qui finalement est en
partie gommée par le contexte national
et international néanmoins est ce que
vous allez discuter avec ses listes
parce que je le disais tout à l'heure
quand on a eu les premières estimations
d'auxerre c'est finalement ces deux
listes écologistes qui tiennent le
résultat entre leurs mains à auxerre
alors je ne fais pas la même année
disent que vous puisque si les deux
listes écologiques écologiste par nom
avait pu s'entendre dès le départ c'est
le maire sortant qui serait en 3e
position donc je pense qu'on serait dans
un autre débat ce soir mais donc vous ne
discuterait pas il n'y a pas de
discussion avec eux je ne sais pas j'ai
à dire c'est très c'est très prématuré
donc effectivement je crois vraiment
qu'on va attendre la décision début de
semaine prochaine concernant le second
tour et ensuite
si effectivement le second tour est
maintenu je pense qu'à ce moment là il y
aura des discussions et je pense qu'on
sera fixée dès demain merci créé sans
barreaux pour cette première réaction en
direct ce soir depuis auxerre où vous
arrivez donc en tête de ce premier tour
de scrutin des élections municipales ou